يبدو ان خطر المقاطع القصيره على مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعي يتعدى فكره اضاعه الوقت
الطويل بالفعل
هنا كبير جدا
التي تلاحق هذه المقاطع عم نحكي عن الريلز
خصوصا بالنسبه للمراهقين الذين يشاهدونها
بكثره
دراسه امريكيه جديده تؤكد ان انتشار
الاجهزه اللوحيه في هذا الزمن التكنولوجي
يحمل اضرارا كبيرا على جيل
الدراسه الامريكيه حملت مقاطع وسائل
التواصل الكثير او حملتها الكثير من
الاسباب التي
تؤاد تحديدا وهذه الاسباب نتعرف عليها مره
اخرى مع جهينه
اسالوا جهينه معلمين
شكرا لكما
نعم الحكايه كبيره بالنسبه لادمان
المراهقين على الريز لكن لماذا تتهم منصات
التواصل بانها السبب نحو 60% من الشباب
يدمنون على منصات التواصل لمده تصل لثلاث
ساعات يوميا ثم يشعرون بالذنب والحزن
لضياع الوقت جميع منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
مصممه اساسا لابقاء المستخدمين على اتصال
دائم بها نظرا للميزات التي تجذب مشتركيها
استراتيجيات هذه المنصات تستهدف الجيل بين
8 الى 23 سنه وتنجح بالتاثير عليهم بشكل
كبير فضلا عن تاثيرها الكبير على مدى
تركيزهم وانتباههم خبراء صحيون اكدوا ان
سبب هذا الادمان ان الشباب يهربون من
العالم الحقيقي الى عالم افتراضيا حالا
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من الرياضه صانع المحتوى
التقنيه صقر عبد الله صقر صبحك الله
بالخير
صباح الخير حياك الله
فيكم استاد المشاهدين حياك الله
يعني اليوم خلصنا من من انستجرام
اليوتيوب سووا الشورت وهذي المقاطع الناس
قاعد تروح لها بانه تقلب ما تخلص من التيك
توك الى سناب شات الى غيره هذا اصبح تحول
الموضوع مو بس عند المراهقين حتى عند
الكبار اصبح ادمان
صحيح صحيح بدايه خلونا نعرف طريقه عمل
البرامج هذه مثل ما سمعنا بالتقرير ان
التطبيقات هذه الرغبه الاولى والتحدي
الاول عندها هو يبقى المتلقي او المشاهد
في تطبيقاتها اطول فتره ممكنه وكيف يتم
الشيء هذا عند التطبيقات هذه توفر لمشاهده
الاشياء اللي هو يحبها
والطريقه صراحه الخوارزميه التطبيقات هذه
تعمل بشكل فعلا عجيب مثلا لما نشوف شخص
مقطع معين في اي من التطبيقات هذه حصلوا
انه يتفاعل معه اي نوع من انواع التفاعل
قد يكون مثلا تعليق يكون لايك مشاهده
الفيديو للكامل او حتى حفظ او نشر المقطع
بالتالي الخوارزمي تفهم الان انه والله
المتلقي هذا ومشاهد حب الفيديو هذا او حب
المشهد هذا خلينا نعطيه فيديوهات مشابهه
فيحصل واحد نفسه
مستمر بمشاهده الفيديوهات هذه بشكل لا
نهائي واربع خصوصا انها قصيره فهو عنده
فرصه انه يشوف المقطع من البدايه للنهايه
ويعرف القصه كامله خلال 30 ثانيه صقر ما
هو هذا هو اللي عم بيصير انه حدا عم بيشوف
المقطع من بدايته لنهايته وعلى الاغلب
يعني يا دوب كم من ثانيه لا تتعدل عشر
ثواني هو فعليا اللي بشوفه من كل فيديو
فهو بصفي من كل ريل فهو بس عم بحرك وهذا
هو ربما الحركه هاي هي اللي بتعمل نوع من
انواع الادمان طيب هل كمان
او خوارزميات مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
بتكون هدفها انه تخلي الشخص مدمن وتخليه
يتابع فبالتالي حسب الفيديوهات اللي بتطلع
لنا اياها كمان فيها نوع من الخبث خلينا
نقول والله خلينا نقول انها هي تستهدف انت
المتنقي وش تحب تشوف هي تقدم لك انا شخصيا
استفدت من مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي بشكل
كبير جدا افادتني في عملي في محتواي في
حتى مصدر رزقي فلما انا اتابع مقاطع معينه
مثلا خلينا نقول على التصوير شروحات
واساليب معينه في التصوير فالاقي نفسي ان
المواقع هذه تطلع لي خيارات اضافيه عن عن
تكنيكات التصوير التكنيكات الاضاءه انا
تعلمت تصوير
يعني يعني اصبحت تطلع لك ما تخليك حتى
تشوف محتوى ثاني غيرها
احسن احسنت فانا انا خلينا ما ودنا نقول
نبرئهم تماما لكن نقول برضو المسؤوليه تقع
على المستخدم في ايش يختار لما يتفاعل او
او يعلق على فيديوهات ما تكون مناسبه له
واكيد راح تطلع لهم
ايديهم من الموضوع هذا لكن
المستخدم والمسؤوليه عنده اكيد احنا يعني
نقول انتبهوا خصوصا على عبد الله يقول لكم
انتبهوا
شكرا جزيلا المحتوى تقني صقر عبدالله كان
معنا من الرياض لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات